but for me I feel like with obsidian
games there's always a very bold
perspective that you can see from a
trailer whether it's the Aesthetics of
pent or kind of like the cheekiness of
like grounded I I forget when it was but
remember when their trailer was like for
the biggest game look to cyber punk you
know like you kind of get the idea of
what the humor is and sort of the the
flavor and the vibe and I feel like with
a vow coming from somebody who has never
played the previous pillars um game
um I don't I don't see what the Bold
sort of like direction is other than me
being like okay it's Elder scres with
like neon powers